a pair of chimpanzees may soon get a new
lease on life thanks to a New York state
judge recognizing them as legal persons
in the ruling by the New York Supreme
Court the two chimps Hercules and Leo
are legally covered by habeas corpus a
law that governs against unfair
detention this means the two chimps
currently being held at Stony Brook
University for biomedical research may
have to be set free the decision came
two years after the nonhuman Rights
Project launched the case to help free
the two chimps
the group plans to launch similar legal
cases for whales dolphins great apes and
elephants I think the story is
completely fascinating you guys know I'm
a big animal lover I you know I'm not a
fan of animal testing generally speaking
I know sometimes there are cases where
we have to do with mice but certainly
not for cosmetics and things like that
we know that what something like 99% of
our genetic makeup is the same as these
chimps and all that kind of stuff so I'm
kind of down with this I love it I just
love the the blatant irony of the fact
that chimps these two at least have more
rights than everybody at Gitmo right
just let it goes that way we're not
giving actual humans habeas corpus
status but we'll give it to chimps I'm
not sure how to judge that but I love
that that's just staring us all yes well
Paul for the record these chimps aren't
on any terror watch list which I don't I
would not I don't know they all they had
those beers you throw banana peel it can
be quite dangerous what do you think
about this is this a slippery somebody's
gonna make a slippery slope argument
right
I look they're adorable I totally get it
but I think it is a little bit of a
slippery slope and then our we're not
gonna be allowed to say things like dude
what a [ __ ] like now we're not gonna be
I get like worse it's all good okay you
know when when they riot
they ride they really rise me the police
are dodging poo so where do you guys
think this goes as far as animal
in general so like chimps I can see the
sort of logic there but then they listen
to my wails and you know the humans have
some special thing about us that we
should be separate from all these things
well mixed feelings about I mean when
you see those Ricky Gervais Instagram
photos of like the white chick next to
the dead giraffe it's like yeah I
totally get it that it makes a lot of
sense yeah but I don't want it to
interfere with how I treat my dog
because it's a doll it's I feel it's a
slippery slope like is it gonna get to
the point where like if I have a dog and
and let's just say for example he has a
little like a fat bubble that's on him
and if I don't get it fixed is there
gonna is the vet gonna get me in trouble
because I'm not getting a fix because
I'm from Kansas and the dog is a effin
dog but I do understand it and I applaud
that that house it is crazy but here's
my question is that how did this come
about like are these chimps not
somebody's property as your dog is your
property right I don't want to get into
the the like arse that language but but
are they no I mean how why isn't this
falling under property law wise is going
into a habeas corpus yeah it just it
just doesn't yeah well I'm not a lawyer
so I don't know I had no idea yeah I
have no idea but to your point about you
know judging people with their own
animals there's a guy on my street who
walks a little a little pug you know
like a 15 pound pug this thing has a
goiter or something some sort of growth
that is literally like half the size of
a basketball like huge huge and I always
want to say that I've seen this dog now
for months and it can barely walk and
it's you know it's almost dragging this
thing and I always want to save it a guy
like are you what's going on here are
you taking care of that or whatever but
I have no right obviously say that what
he's doing her will we be able to pay
chimps 70% on a dollar yes yeah
and women get 77 what does that say
about it all right so it's Chevy seven
I'm sorry so wait what you're saying is
it should be 80 cents for the chimps and
77 cents I think if we make if we make
chimps if we put them in the same
category as human beings we identify
them legally as humans we'll have
slavery again I know somebody will come
along and start selling slave chimps
anyway let us know what you think in the
comments right now